What's the difference between the clear hiss or natural clear hiss and the clear
histamine scavenger? So what you're dealing with histamine issues? You have to
experiment a little bit with supplements to pull histamines out of your body
because there's a lot of different nutritional anti-inflammatories to help pull
histamines. The standards that are out there are the corsetin and some other
things. That's in the clear hiss. I think the clear hiss has like a word
different to the gradients. The histamine scavenger is just a totally different
product. It has more and types of nutrients in there. Some people do just so
much better on the histamine scavenger and the clear hiss doesn't do anything
for them and some people do really well on the clear hiss and not the histamine
scavenger doesn't do anything for them. So you just have to experiment. Now these two
are completely different than another product out there called the
hista clear. So the hista clear is completely different. That is a DAO enzyme. So the
DAO enzyme is produced in your tissues through the HNMTV and it's produced in
your gut through the DAO HDAO gene. And defects in either one of those
genes is going to produce less of that. So the DAO enzyme is what clears
histamine, what breaks down histamine in your tissues and in the gut. Well, you
can take the DAO enzyme straight. That's what hista clear is. It's kind of
expensive. It comes to like a dollar a pill, but it doesn't absorb. So it'll
only work in the gut. So if your problem is a lot of histamine in the gut or you
have huge histamine problems because of dietary histamines, then you use
hista clear when you're eating foods or when you're trying to calm down the
inflammation of the gut. Hista clear will not pull histamines out of the tissues.
So clear hist, natural clear hist, it's also and clear histamine scavenger pulls
histamine out of the tissues. Those are just different types of products that
you're going to have to experiment with. So you have to try. If you've been using
the clear histid, it's like it's not really working. Just try the histamine
scavenger and see if that works better for you.